so as I was saying earlier you guys have
probably been bombarded with email from
me and I actually learned about it from
our next speaker Neville Medora so if
you've heard of appSumo he's one of the
guys who have made that so popular they
send out about 10 million emails a month
and he's the brains behind it and it's
been working pretty well in fact he has
he's actually created one of the
top-selling copywriting courses in the
whole world and just in the past two
years it's not about 2 million in
revenue just from one single copywriting
course so Neville's gonna touch upon
copywriting and and how he's been able
to use that to grow up his business so
let's go welcome Neville Medora all
right so what I'm gonna talk to you
today is this formula it sounds really
scammy but like this formula that
everyone and your company will write
better but it's actually true I'm gonna
give it a little background on this
so at appSumo and a lot of the other
companies I'm involved with we send out
a ton of emails I do a lot of consulting
for this for all sorts of companies just
like yours big companies mid-sized
companies and we see their email and
their copy every day and they all make
big mistakes so let me if I could figure
this stuff out all right so this is a
typical kind of email that you'll see in
the morning when you're taking a dump
checking your phone and you'll delete it
pretty quickly right now the weird that
is by the way how most people check
their email and so and so the funny
thing about this is they have really
high click-through rates because look at
all this there's like view deal there's
images everywhere there's text there's
enough things on this page to probably
grab your attention at some point right
so probably click it but the problem is
with these guys emails low engagement
like there's nothing really to do with
this email other than click out of it
and get out of it as fast as possible
the other thing is people are really
quick to unsubscribe and if your
business is dependent on email or you
know how hard it is to get white-label
email delivery all that kind of stuff
then that's money lost so I want to talk
to you about a different style the total
opposite of this kind of newsletter
style email is the more personal looking
yo Joe update my slides I don't think
y'all did so this is a very personal
looking sorry this is gonna be a little
interesting so this is a more personal
looking email it's just text it's like
from a single person so it'll be like at
the end sincerely Neville you know it
won't be from appSumo it won't be from
your company necessarily and so the
thing about these is they have pretty
good click-through rates it's not bad
it's just a very small decline from the
newsletter style but very high
engagement very very high engagement and
the cool thing is people hang on to
every word that you write if you write
cool stuff right so if your copy is
educational for most that's the number
one thing that we put in so I had this
business called house of rave epic till
2011 I owned a rave company I've never
been to rave in my whole life but I
owned a rave coming so light a Pingo
stuff and so here everyone told me like
dude you have to send out emails like
the money is in the email list like it's
like your personal atm they say that
stuff like that so I'm like okay oh make
some emails and basically what I did is
I had all these people opted in to an
email list already that were paying
customers okay so here we're the old
email and check this out look it I was
so proud of these by the way I can't
tell you how is static I was the sund'ys
out and look it had a date on the top I
designed that logo myself in Photoshop I
made all this and Photoshop myself
I took all these pictures I made those
big buttons right just very clickable
and like I said about these newsletter
styles with lots of images what happened
well there's like this so the list size
was 7500 of previous customers that have
already bought from me
lots of opens that's that's much above
industry average because people click on
them but here's the thing no
sales so what difference does it make
like it didn't matter it didn't matter
if I got a ton of opens it's just no
sales and the profit because I would put
discounts at the end of these I'll do
everything that we were supposed to but
it discount at the end I would make like
$40 in profit meanwhile vertical
response my email service pro right at
the time cost $80 a month and well you
just do the math that was negative $40
every time like I sent out an email
every month it was it was stupid so then
we went to this oh let me let me do
something else I think that kind of
screwed up my slides here so
let me demonstrate for you the power of
copy okay so I've got two envelopes over
here and they're both adjust to my mom
or we can say our mom for this situation
right mom okay so we're gonna send her a
little letter and all we're doing is
just putting a little piece of paper
stamp address the center and off this
first letter is gonna say dear mom I'm
very busy right now I don't have time to
call so I'm writing you with this letter
you know mom not only are you
responsible for my very existence we are
the nourishment that has made my life
Sparkle so I'm under a lot of stress
right now and it occurred to me that
lately I haven't let you know how much I
appreciate and love you sincerely
Neville oh very sweet right yes fold
this up put in the envelope send it off
now we'll take the other identical
envelope addressed a mom also and we're
gonna write this same piece of paper
same stamp same address same envelope
dear mom if I wasn't such a long way
from home I probably wouldn't have the
guts to tell you this but the following
has been true ever since I was born you
have made my life a complete living hell
I'm jealous of every person on earth
because they all have better mother's
than I do you are nothing but a wrinkled
up old and the biggest waste of
skin God ever created eat and died
sincerely Neville PS dad sucks too we
put this in the envelope and send it now
as you can imagine there's going to be
like a slight variance in those two
envelopes right one your mom will be
crying and happy in tears the other
should be crying and ever want to talk
to you again except maybe Sam's mom
because she probably hates them anyway
Sam I hope you hear that so anyhow
that's the power of copy just a little
bit rearranging the words completely
changes the outcome and we've seen this
on split test after split test after
split test it makes a huge difference
and for those engineers in here like
listen up because sometimes I'll write
really shitty copy but we'll teach you
how to fix that today
so the
next thing I did with that house of rave
remember remember these like these
crappy newsletters they looked cool but
they didn't perform well check this out
this is the next one I started learning
how to copy right from a guy named Gary
Halbert he's dead now but he's had all
this cool stuff I started assessing
about copyrighting every time I flew in
a plane I'd look at the SkyMall and be
like oh I bet I can improve the copy on
that one I bet I can prove the copy on
that dog bed like it was really fun to
do and so I went through and with the
help of this formula that I'm teaching
you today I wrote this email it doesn't
really matter what it says right now
I'll give you all this stuff later at
the end of the presentation but
basically this single email zero
formatting it wasn't even a table or
anything zero no no real customization
whatsoever except a few bolts and there
was only really one link it says get
your finger lights I was selling
light-up iglo stuff get your finger
lights that's all I had run this
promotion through a regular style
newsletter before and it sold nothing I
ran the same promotion like this the
results the same size opens were sight
less than the 35 before about 120 sales
in the first two hours so I was very
happy that day like I made a lot of
money that day we sold out of all the
product and people were ecstatic to try
to get more so the only difference was I
just wrote good copy on that one and I
followed a style of copy and this
formula that I'm about to teach you
right here and I just followed it
exactly filled in the blanks and then
flushed it out and that was the whole
thing so does anyone know what this is
already
Adah heavens anyone ever heard of that a
few of you yeah Kim nice okay good so
then everyone's gonna be surprised well
the magic formula is ADA uh y'all
up my slides damn it
okay we're gonna have to roll with this
so here's the here's the ADA thing a I D
a so what that means is attention
interest desire action you may have seen
this on that movie Glengarry Ross where
he's like ADA always be selling ADA
right but this is actually a formula
that copywriters for like 80 200 years
have you successfully over and over and
over and here's the thing I hate using
stupid formulas like this but every time
I try to divert from it it fails every
time I use it it works so just of
probably over the billion emails like
I've
none that have actually gone out this
always works it's unbelievable how well
this works take a picture with your
phone or whatever and like I said at the
end I'll give all this to you so what
you're supposed to do is next time you
sit down to write copy have you ever
done this like you sit down your boss or
someone is like oh right this email or
sales or pitch this person and you sit
down and you get like this like shitty
computer typing itis well you're just
like dear Sirs we would like to
introduce our product it is very
technical it's like no one cares right
so it's said if you just use this ADA
formula it will solve that problem for
you so you get their attention grab
their attention interest them with
interesting facts uses stats examples
numbers work very well testimonials work
very well their desire make them come to
the conclusion that I want this like
don't try to like sell them let them
like be sold and then come to you like
that's really good and then at the end a
lot of people who do this tell them
exactly how to buy do you have to click
a PayPal button what's gonna happen
after that are you gonna get something
in the mail or get something ml what's
gonna happen so that's the basic outline
of the formula so in one minute you can
fill this out and have a basic structure
of a sales page so this can be used for
an email it could be used for a
long-form sales page it could be used
for any sort of pitch to an investor or
anyone this is the scientific way that
you hit people's brains to make them
sell attention interest desire action
okay so for example I'm trying to sell
you this Aida formula right now I'm not
trying to sell you anything for money
I'm just trying to sell you a concept
right so what would I do for this well
this is the structure I use for everyone
no matter how big the company this is
the formula we always use this is the
formula that end up copying and two
years later when I check on how they're
doing everyone in the company is using
this formula still because it's so good
this this format so what we do is write
a couple of subject lines over there the
ADA formula subject to a formula that
will make you and everyone in your
company write better so forth so forth
and then for attention I would just tell
you I can make you sell anything better
with a small formula interest when this
formula is applied to everything it
usually has between a 60% and 300%
increase in everything emails anything
desire every great copywriter for the
last 80 years has stuck to this simple
formula cell and it works because it's
been time-tested and then action take
out a sheet of paper and write the
acronym aid
AI da on it or at least snap a picture
with your phone okay so that's how I
would sell you and I didn't really have
to like do a lot of brain stuff over
here just you just follow a formula so
let's try to sell someone a concept
using ADA let's get someone to uh to
drink more water I'll bring my water
bottle up here no I had a prop but I
forgot to bring it so if I was trying to
get you to drink more water I could just
say like hey man in the leopard skin
suit I could be like hey drink more
water it's good for you right and you'd
probably be like okay whatever yeah like
big whoop right now let's apply ADA to
this situation God y'all really
up my slides I'm sorry they were way
better than this so so one of the things
I could tell you is like hey man do you
work out at all okay so you work out so
you go to the gym for like an hour each
time or something like that well did you
know that like if you drink more water
in your system you actually get 30% more
games like the way your muscles work is
they tear right whenever you lift really
heavy weights so whenever they rebuild
what do you think are rebuilding with
that 70% water weight they're always
talking about so the amino acids react
with the protein and the water to form
muscle fibers and if you have more water
an overabundance of water in your system
you actually at 30% more gains this is
like a proven fact okay so the next time
you go to the gym all you have to do is
chug like a liter of water before and
you'll get 30 percent gains extra for
the same workout right that's like if I
filled up your gas your tank of gas in
your car
and took away 30 percent of it you'd be
pretty pissed at that right well if you
go to the gym and work out for an hour
and I take away a lot of that time be
pretty pissed also so just drink an
extra liter of water before the gym and
that's how I would sell it using the ADA
formula now that's actually total
I don't know if that actually
works by weight I just made that up
but so don't go drinking a lot more
water in the gym I'm sure it can't be
bad but I don't know if it works I took
this slide out but whatever this is
about length of copy copy is like a
woman's going out whatever
grabbing okay so now so a lot of people
have this trouble so especially in
companies big companies like these older
people will be like oh but you're you're
young and creative you could come up
with these things we can't come up with
them Engineers will typically give me
that example right and so here's the
easy way to come up with here's another
formula to get writing really well also
I assume how many of you have like
startup kind of companies where you have
like a webpage you spent time putting up
a web page yeah a lot of them really
really suck and if you notice like the
design that the trend in design is to
put a really killer headline and then
like you know enter your something here
or whatever this is the way you find
those so a specific result a customer
wants specific period of time and then
address the objection that's it that's
that's the whole goddamn formula it's
super easy so check this out we'll do
some examples over time so the end
result customer wants specific period of
time and adjust objections feel free to
move these around and mix and match or
even try it out on your own company
right now as I'm doing these examples
feel free to write it out whatever don't
pay attention to me so for example if
you're like a consultant or something
the main headline like the little
quote-unquote elevator pitch here's a
one sentence pitch okay increase the
conversions are your Shopify store in
three days or I'll refund your money
okay that's pretty simple right like
there's really really no
misunderstanding that statement hey if
you were just like oh I'm a consultant
on e-commerce and we try to it's just
like use a bunch of buzzwords and stuff
you lose people and frankly it's also
boring so the other way is wipe away
your debt before your tax return is due
so the IRS won't call that sounds like a
really scam you add that another one is
linked up your social media account in
five minutes so you can post in one
place but share on all I think that's
like buffer basically and then track
where your customers click so you can
increase conversions by this week that's
kind of a crazy example so that's how
you get these headlines like this is a
really helpful formula and result
customer one specific period of time
address the objections I don't know what
slide they have next so we'll say yeah
this tacos oh you took out the other
good stuff all right
so I guess I'm almost out of time anyway
so
if I helped you one thing I want to
tattoo this in your brain Aida oka I da
it's like aids but ADA it's really
really simple so the next time you sit
down and write an email or something
like that for example Sam made an
autoresponder for this place which
happens to be packed today and he used
ADA on all those emails I don't know if
you noticed that you probably didn't if
you didn't know this formula but that's
how he wrote them he had to write a
bunch of emails in a row just use ADA on
every single one of them and it turned
out great
so ate a template oh god these are all
old versions okay so if you want all the
stuff I sent over here you can share it
with your company or yourself or steal
this presentation whatever you want to
do you can text nev to 5500 it's not
gonna collect your email or anything
like that i had a link other here it's
copywriting course comm with Ches slash
hustle con you'd also just download it
directly from there and that's it so
thank you everybody
push it am I supposed to stand up here
by myself what happens
we got a Q&A right now so maybe ten
minutes of Q&A if there is questions for
Neville come on down I've taken this
course by the way oh thank you and it's
very good so I'm a happy customer you
will be too I've been trying to learn
this stuff for the past couple months
one of the things that I'm a little bit
concerned about is that you know no
offense at all but like I feel like a
lot of the emails I get that are like in
this style just sounds like like really
weird and like sushi and like annoying
it's like like the voice is just like I
hate this person emailing me but it
works so like where's the subtle cues as
he's looking at me
so like we get this objection all the
time keep going yeah so like why do you
think about like I mean we just got this
talk from Chubby's about like being
authentic to your brand voice I'm like
so howdy if your values aren't around
like this sort of attention grabby
BuzzFeed type stuff like how do you how
do you balance that with wanting to
write great copy obviously okay so
that's the number one thing that any
company comes up to me and says they're
just let they'll see like appSumo which
is it's written in the voice it used to
be written in the voice
this 500-pound sumo and we make fat
jokes and quite racist jokes actually
all the time
sorry I heard 3 sorry that was kind of a
bad execution of that did no one see
that thing on the bottom of the first
three people to bark like a dog in a
free book ah nice I guess that's too
small so anyways what what the thing is
about that is whatever so people think
you have to write goofy right they
associate this with like goofy like
attention-grabbing kind of like
that not this isn't about link bait type
stuff like viral Nova or something like
that this isn't about that
so a lot of times the stuff I write is
actually very serious I don't think a
lot of people see that for the banking
sector and everything like that that
stuff is serious but the underlying
thing about it I told you the number one
thing and sorry my slides are all messed
up but the number one thing is educating
the customer in those emails so if you
have a boring style but you have a
really if you're really strongly
passionate about something you can be
boring and still sell this in that same
format so the ADA formula doesn't mean
act like a stupid jackass all the time
it means it means it's you're hitting
points in a customer's head like the
psychological points to help them sell a
little bit better so if you go to a
appSumo compre PR u Y that's tracking
software for your Mac I actually got
robbed a long time ago and we're trying
to sell we're trying to promote this
thing and I was like how do I do this I
it's not a very funny story about like
how I got robbed and they stole my Max
and it actually made me go a little bit
insane right like you walk in your house
and I was like I'm looking through every
room and like I would close my windows
at night I get really paranoid about
everything so I wrote a whole story of
how that affected me so much like I felt
violated
when I got robbed I was a sight that's
like a thing to feel but that's
how I felt and so I wrote about that and
it was completely serious and and
vulnerable and that sold like crazy also
but it was a real story there was no
humor there was no kind of like it was
just a story so you do not have to act
crazy or like some of the old direct
response marketers that are I know you
talked about scammy douchey or like the
whole IM marketing field avoid all that
yeah I got you I know
how much time do you spend a week on
your email marketing campaigns a lot of
times I find with my marketing mix it
falls to the bottom because it can be so
time-consuming email marketing campaigns
what are you trying to do like what what
I'm working on but pretty much anything
like writing an entire email marketing
campaign you did all once in a couple of
days and then okay so so normally what I
try to do is I try to break up the
broadcast as they come in so if it's if
it's just like a one-time thing you
write it as it is I literally start with
the templates I gave subject purpose of
this email beta if I'm doing a big
autoresponder I use Google Docs for
everything I use Google Docs for
everything actually and then I make I
make that same template subject line
blah blah blah and then I paste it like
eight times let's say there's eight
emails in that autoresponder I post the
whole thing in a Google Doc I write the
first email and then I think how can I
tie this into the second email and so
forth and that's how I write it and then
I load those all up at one time yeah so
then when people read them they're like
oh these flow together very well but if
you wrote them individually and uploaded
them to your email software whatever it
would be kind of complicated yeah and it
usually takes like between an hour and
two hours to write an email yeah or
sometimes shorter if I know exactly what
I want to write hey how's it going yo I
have a question for it seems like a lot
of what you do is b2c I'm guessing
mostly yeah so how do you do that for
business-to-business because this this
same thing works for business business
same thing we help people with the same
thing all the time and they're always
like oh this only works for b2c think
about it b2b means business of business
there's still like a person at the end
okay yeah it's not like some business
entity there's a person at the end
reading that boring email okay and
they don't like to be bored also so you
don't have to be wacky but at the same
time instead of just talking about your
company all the time what we've seen
with salespeople little little sidenote
salespeople in the b2b industry are the
people who've used my course and
increase their income the most I was
kind of shocked by that but then I
realized these people email or call ten
people a day right they're like hey
we're from Acme bricks and we make the
best bricks and we've been around since
nineteen
and we're based in Cleveland and Bob and
it's like that's not interesting okay
but if they just send one simple email
that kind of engages the other person in
terms of like hey we see that you're
using our competitor strawberry bricks
we actually sell our bricks for 40%
cheaper interested and they don't even
write their company name or maybe the
right like Acme or something like that
that has the highest response rate and
highest business getting rate that we've
ever seen and so this stuff definitely
works in b2b very short if you're trying
to just do that first introduction email
you know if someone introduces you their
cell think about it in real life okay
that's how you communicate with your
email list in like in real life
but I came up to you I was like hey my
name is novel and I grew up in Austin
Texas a bubble and go on and on you
eventually get tired and move away right
unless that was really hot in which case
you might come closer but but other than
that like you you just want to say like
a quick hello it's it's just quick and
then something of real interest to them
that's all it's quite simple I already
gave the books away hi it's quick
question about the templates one of them
had like four subjects yes what was the
purpose of that to get your mind right
so if I was right like how to sell ada
or like come to hustle con it is awesome
that might not be the best way the best
angle to look at selling hustle con
right it might be there might be
something different so I write for
subjects just to like get my mind
jogging and honestly you could write a
lot more so it's like a brainstorming
just kind of together it's good guy yeah
and even at appSumo we made a plug-in
called King King sumo that has it it's a
headline plugin that you put into
WordPress and instead of just typing a
one title on WordPress you type in as
many titles as you want so I'll type in
like ten titles and it'll automatically
split tests in a smart way the the right
one and oftentimes you'd be surprised
and I'm not talking about once again
like not not linkbait kind of things
like Oh number seven will blow your mind
sadly that does work temporarily in this
day and age but not for the long term
and so so yeah you can do that and I
write different subjects because I get
different ideas it's really helpful very
quick full up do you ever do maybe
testing
in email taught in emails yeah all the
time yeah it makes a huge difference
did you software for that all yeah well
you can use I mean if you use
Infusionsoft Infusionsoft as if you use
a web where you can use Aweber you could
do ghetto forms of split testing we
don't spent too too much time doing that
because if you build up goodwill with
your whole email base they tend to open
your emails all the time and so even if
it's a crappy email you get some leeway
like if like I like Sam and if he you
know tells me something if it's bad one
time like he sends me a bad joke I don't
just like get rid of him as a friend he
has a whole like he has a whole
repertoire with me right so I'll still
look at his stuff and be like okay
forgiven for that one but then we move
on so so we do subject line test a
little bit but we don't go like super
overboard with it yeah oh good I have a
question for you yeah my name is Eric
I'm really curious to hear how long it
takes you to write an email because
earlier today we had Rohan gar from
pricin Dominick's he said that a blog
post takes in 40 hours he's talking
about the data collection yeah the data
collection so kind of my questions
related to you know your thoughts on
including things like data because
you're kind of more of a storyteller in
your style oh but that is great if you
have data use data by all means yeah and
I mean what's your process I mean in
terms of like start to finish in time
and you know how you start thinking
about writing the copy and so forth it
completely depends what you're talking
about right if let's say we have a deal
at absolutement I want to promote
Optimizely right what I'll do is I'll
download Optimizely
I'll use some of the things I'll install
it on my website usually that stuff
takes way longer or like we've tried to
promote Wistia before and we're starting
to use Wistia the video provider and I
had to I use Wistia I uploaded my own
videos I liked it I used all the
features I embedded on my website that
was all the data that I was looking for
so that's data in my case we have a one
last question quick question if I want
to do a test I'll be the smallest sample
you'll take you can send a newsletter
style email
are you just starting out or you have
like a big thing going already but you
have like a large email base already to
go okay so then then so I mean absent
we'll do tests of ten thousand people
each yeah I've done I've been small
tests on my own list where you send a
thousand people one email and then a
thousand people another email so you
send one of those newsletter style
emails where it's just like a group on
looking email and say click here and
then you'll see the difference between
that and then you also see the
difference between just like writing a
properly formatted email out here's the
problem with testing a lot of people get
really into this testing thing like oh
what can I it's like short term gains
okay so one of the things we noticed
whenever we started we started split
testing the out of our headlines
and our prices and the problem is it
worked
temporarily temporarily there was like
this time where it was it went like this
but then people just started getting
tired of it right when they start seeing
different prices all the time for it
like you open up an email one time you
see a different price and you see on a
website's different price people get
people don't like feeling cheated right
and so if you build up goodwill over
time you don't need to do as much split
testing and so while the numbers show
that you might get slightly higher
click-through rates on just like a
newsletter style thing that's great if
that's all you're going for but if you
want people to read your emails that
interact with them and also like there's
a cool trick that if you get people to
respond to your emails at the bottom
right hey respond to me let me know what
your issue with Optimizely is when they
respond it kind of whitelist you so it
goes more into the the inbox instead of
the promotions box on Gmail that was
actually a slide I had thanks for
it up guys and it's so yeah so
just try small test like that
split test would you try to it's it's
it's just two versus four I don't
know it doesn't matter doesn't
matter Thank You Bridget
you